russia has been massing troops near its
border with ukraine for weeks
the prospect of a possible attack has
triggered tense negotiations and
diplomatic efforts as the u.s and nato
have been trying to discourage russia
from taking military action and that
makes it very difficult for ukraine as
well being almost surrounded
the stakes are high the west has
threatened sanctions and military
deployment by nato
while moscow says it doesn't plan to
invade the country it wants to have a
say in ukraine's future
since ukraine was invaded by russian
troops in 2014 it has strengthened its
own military and many ukrainians say
they're ready to fight
but what happens now also depends on
whether tensions between the u.s and
russia keep escalating
moscow began stationing troops and
military equipment near ukraine in
december of last year as was documented
by satellite images
by early january 100 000 troops were
amassed not far from ukraine's border
president putin has long claimed ties to
ukraine a former soviet republic and has
repeatedly indicated that he wants it
back under russia's influence in recent
years ukraine has sought to join nato in
the eu
these blocks are not offering membership
but putin has accused them of turning
ukraine into an anti-russia on his
country's borders
ukraine's president vladimir silanski
said nato has an interest in supporting
kiev to contain any fallout of a russian
attack that could affect its member
states especially in eastern europe
in the past russia has resorted to
military action to keep ukraine
close when the country ousted its
pro-russian president in a revolution in
early 2014 moscow responded by seizing
crimea in southern ukraine
that war and other conflicts involving
pro-russian separatists in recent years
have fueled a wave of ukrainian
nationalism according to some
sociologists before 2014 a lot of people
felt quite positively about russia now a
lot of people in ukraine see it as an
invader one third of respondents in a
poll late last year indicated they would
take up arms to defend the country if it
was attacked
this woman has been training as a
reservist in the ukrainian army for 18
months
i came here
to territory defense forces to have
skills
to
use the gun to defend myself to defend
my family
from
possible russian aggression
ukraine which is the largest country in
the region apart from russia said it's
been strengthening its military and
prepared its people to fight there's
also a fighting spirit that has improved
since since 2014 people who are ready to
defend that country not only in the army
but also volunteers people bringing help
to those who are ready to fight
still there are also residents in
ukraine's border regions who say they
feel more closely tied to russia than
the west
the u.s and nato have offered their
support although western allies remain
divided
the white house has previously ruled out
sending troops on the ground in ukraine
but has sent weaponry and other
equipment to the country having approved
200 million dollars in such assistance
if they actually do what they're capable
of doing with the force amassed on the
border it is going to be a disaster for
russia
other nato members also sent arms to
ukraine while the block increased
deployments of troops and equipment in
its eastern member states
but some european countries like germany
and italy were reluctant to take
stronger action partly because they are
major importers of energy from russia
russia will be held accountable so far
the biden administration's main strategy
has been the threat of crippling
economic sanctions on russia which
hasn't backed down on its demands and
continued military activity along the
border